guys you're watching each other for
dinner but first we got a video sponsor
from a guitar
wow daughter music instruments maybe
a whole music company they could get
guitars they got keyboards drums
recording equipment anything you need
the second they hit us up i was like
yeah i want a guitar
and they make a lot of great stuff and
it's all affordable why don't we just
let the music yeah for itself all right
so what john are gonna do we're just
gonna pass the guitar back and forth and
we're just gonna
show off our guitar skills and all the
stuff you know john why don't you go
first buddy
[Music]
it's just chili peppers all right
[Music]
[Music]
it's hurt by johnny cash that's all i
[Music]
know
two three four
i think something's wrong with the
strings oh no we can replace all the
strings at donner
[Music]
remember james james blunt
[Music]
[Applause]
well guys if you want to be as great of
a guitar player as both
john and i go pick up yourself a donner
musical instrument today
[Music]
my planet arrakis is so beautiful when
the sun is low
[Music]
rolling over the sands you can see spice
in the air
let the spice flow the outsiders ravage
our lands in front of our eyes
their cruelty to my people is all i've
known
what's to become of our world
that hans zimmer score man duncan can i
trust you or something
yes always you know that i've been
having dreams
about a girl or maracas i don't know
what it means
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake
yeah you put on some muscle i didn't no
[Applause]
we are house atreides there is no call
we do not answer
there is no faith that we betrayed
[Music]
smile gurney i am smiling
just to bring peace
accept
[Music]
you need to face your fears
conquer fear come with me
ready you've never met harkins before
we're not human they're brutal
the duke's son sees too much
this is why you kill them all
set the title except the title god in
heaven
[Music]
get everything with guns off the ground
go
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight by demons
dad what if i'm not the future of house
of tradies
a great man doesn't seek to lead he's
called to it
but if your answer is no
that's scary my son
if anything happens
will you protect paul with my life
all together can we stand a chance
[Music]
oh great that looks awesome
what a fantastic score holy crap
yeah that was an amazing score
that's that's going to be the new
workout song workout song right there
yeah as you learn to conquer fear
yeah on the stairmasters
well i hope this movie makes a gazillion
dollars
it needs to i think this is one movie
for knee village sake that i'm hoping is
able to climb its way
to way surpassing its budget
bottom line this must be seen in the
theaters you will not be seeing an hbo
max
reaction from us this one needs to get a
sequel because this is only a part one
right
yeah because there's someone who is a
big dune fan
oh you're just gonna let me have this
moment could you you just go okay
you want to be if you want to be a dune
expert you're just like all right i
prepared a whole bit about how i read
only the first three pages but now okay
you're gonna
okay you're gonna bring in your book go
ahead go go go go go
sound smart talk about paul the tradies
and all that
go go for it go i said go
uh this looks like dune i'm curious to
know what dune fans think because it's
honing in on the action and the
spaceships and the sci-fi and the sand
worms was that worth it was that worth
overtaking my just gonna let me have it
just gotta be like oh he's just bringing
out his book i'm going to bring it up
hoping this
conversation would be like way to go
john thank you i'm never going to do
that again what's funny is once i
brought my book i'm like i bet john's
going to bring out his book i knew it i
just
knew it what do you i don't even have a
book i don't know what you're talking
about
all right guys well john thank you for
that amazing input there
way to overshadow my hilarious bit
good three pages though right three
pages hopefully before
it comes out i'll finish that bible over
there i mean i've seen
at least the last for adaptation what's
being pulled off here
looks obviously grand and epic and all
of its scale
the cast itself is probably the most
appealing part to me i don't know about
you guys but
once thanos said i am smiling it's like
how do you not think of
that i'm saying that you know what i
mean but this does put a smile on my
face
everything about here looks very
emotionally
swelling it goes without saying you know
denis villeneuve one thing that he's a
master of his crafting with his
cinematographer and the composition of
this whole thing just feels so
glorious to behold and i think that
there is a lot of emotional pull to be
happening here
however it's it's dune i think this
trailer is
is doing its best to keep it as focused
as possible not that i think it would be
disjointed it's just this trailer gives
you a reel
we're rapping up to war we're ramping up
to battle vibe you know
it's probably gonna be way more
deliberate
a lot more uh ethereal in the way how
it's all done i
imagine the tone will probably have more
of this like
menacing vibe underneath it all but it's
gonna be
way slower than what this trailer is
probably trying to tell you
it's a trailer so it's got to pitch you
on the the epicness it's got to pitch
you on the build
you got your protagonist and the
villains and then you got some mystery
you know clouded but they're trying to
keep it mainly on just this one plot
about paula tradies having to overcome
his fear for his family
go against the bad guys but there's
going to be so many like things to
explore
throughout here that's the thing with
denise villanues films is they always
have like a
pulsating trailer but then you watch the
movies and especially with the property
that is dune
it's gonna be a long dramatic sci-fi
movie yeah
yeah absolutely and i mean this
definitely has those earmarks of like a
real
epic that you know has all those
production values of like a lord of the
rings rather than like a summer sci-fi
action blockbuster so like
that combined with what i know about
denis villeneuve has me excited about
this like as a trailer
it's really cool it does remind me a lot
of the previous dune just in what
they're showing us
and in that this has to kind of surpass
that and be
the movie that that movie very much was
not i am curious to see what the actual
you know
conceptual side of the movie winds up
being because if there's one thing i
know about
dune it inspired many you know sci-fi
action swashbucklers but it's not really
about
that itself it's much more yeah society
religion
emotion you know things like that and so
that's kind of the main thing i'm still
curious about because like all the
designs and effects
and every physical element looks really
beautiful and
and as a sci-fi world i mean it looks
quite desolate but it's very wonderfully
hewn so yeah now i'm just like
waiting to see what you know uh
qualitative stuff is going to set it
apart because at least on the action and
the
you know sci-fi side looks amazing i
think on a challenge
such as this for something like dune
weirdly for adapting a film you got so
many characters here i think when you
have an ensemble of this
caliber it can be very easy to go i
really like this actor i really love
this guy's performance the part
that can honestly kind of be the most
challenging and this might
as my piss off some people but kind of
hear me out if you if you can if you can
try to if you
try hear me out for a journey on this
scale we have to really care about
timothy chalamet we have to really be
emotionally invested in him and not
feel this sort of detachment trailer's
showing you so many things
sometimes i could find that to be the
case on a first installment when you
have this many characters going around
and with the kind of character paul
tradies is after what denise villanue
did
with blade runner 2049 main character
was ryan gosling and granted ryan
gosling doesn't have to speak at all and
you could be really invested in him but
how much investment i had in his
character in that movie i feel like
it'll translate over to here as well
i just think when you're adapting
something like dune oftentimes you get
really caught up
in everything else the the themes the
production design as
great as it looks it feels like
plausible realistic adaptation
that you can do to it feels a little
more grounded in its approach same time
though when you got this
level of cast and characters like we
have to really make sure that the main
thing is that we're invested in our main
hero
yeah the script has to be on point yeah
because here we go
all sort of caster jason mull looks
great everyone looks great justin what
timothy chalamet oscar isaac
you know thanos poe trax
uh willy wonka yeah man
yeah isn't it chalamet willy wonka yeah
oh damn david dallas malcolm said this
too i love that guy
he's got like one shot from afar in this
trailer it might sound like
like the most obvious thing to say i do
think that it could be the linchpin
in between making this movie that much
more of a success
you gotta surpass kyle mclaughlin he is
sort of an it actor so for me
i am sort of like okay i am waiting to
see him really
you know arise to this role and i'm
hoping that the movie
doesn't lose him in the overall scope of
just adventure and spice and uh
interdimensional ability well i think
with the landscape and kind of the mood
that dune provides everything feels very
desolate so naturally when you're
looking at the performances here
other than a few moments of some charm
and some yelling and whatever and i'm
the biggest fan of
subtle acting i think when you're in an
environment like this or a movie like
this
usually that lends itself to a bit of a
character's feeling a little bit hollow
or detached
i don't mean that yeah i don't mean that
in a bad way yeah
it just makes it a little bit more
challenging in a movie like this to get
you that much more invested in your
characters
everyone's a stoic badge just has to
save the cat at one point
absolutely save the sand cat save a sand
worm all right guys well what did you
think about the dune trailer i think it
looks awesome it looks absolutely
beautiful
the music is just wow that was that was
enriching as hell leave your thoughts
down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button
we'll catch you guys soon
[Music]
absolutely over the johnny cash cords
the much more easy to play cards
[Music]
you